was where the missile struck and it
caused fire except this car Ablaze
pretty much this one has burnt itself
out some of the others have gone up in
Flames as well
and these things have been all these
type of incidents have been going on for
months and months now there has been a
bit of a lull uh in recent weeks the uh
Ukrainian military says that about well
at least 80 Rockets were fired at
Ukraine among some cruise missiles 34
the Air Force say were taken out now
some of these incidents are actually
because of the air defense systems they
actually either hit the rocket perhaps
it doesn't explode or their their own
Rockets come down to earth
um you know quite a lot of people fight
at least six people
um have died in this incident they say
it's across all of the country and that
is what the Russians are trying to do
they're not actually aiming for
residential areas like this they're
trying to hit the energy infrastructure
and this is a sort of the collateral
damage of War you know we ask local
people you know are they getting used to
it after all this time and the simple
fact is they're not they're actually
really really angry but they're not
getting used to it and a number of
people say they live
here and they are scared all the time
because in the very early hours of the
morning
this type of thing happens however I've
yet to meet anyone who says that their
resistance won't continue nobody's
calling for Ukraine to do anything but
continue fighting Russian